[Music]
all right grace
grace so where are you from originally
where'd you grow up i'm from san diego
california um i've been there my entire
life so
tell me about your family
my
mom
passed away when i was one from lung
cancer
and my birth father is not in my life
anymore
um
he
when i was aft when my mom passed away
um
my father's drug use got really bad and
it got to the point where
it was by uh i was like two i think um
i had already had um cps reports
when
my mom
um had me
she was she tested positive for drugs
and so
immediately i got removed from her um
and placed with my dad
and
after
after a while
they were still living together and
everything but i was in his custody and
about when maybe one and a half she had
passed away and
as time got
farther along uh my
dad started getting
worse
in his addiction like he didn't
it was almost like he was a completely
different person after she passed away
um
[Music]
meth was like the main cause
of his issues that he had but i think it
was also just the blame of like losing
my mom
and
he
started
to get really aggressive
and i remember one time
he had gotten so violent that we had
gotten kicked out of our house that we
lived in when i was about three we got
kicked out and we were living on the
streets for a while
um
we were
trash can diving
for the longest time and i i have like
visual memory of that which is weird
because i was so young
um
there was one time
where we were sitting
in front of a 99 cent store at like
three in the morning and
some random person came by and decided
to pick me up and start running with me
just running down the street
and
if that person wouldn't have stopped and
dropped me
i don't know what would have happened
because
he was so high he didn't care
and
eventually after a while being on the
streets we moved into a boat house
and
most of my memories there were
sitting
on a top deck just like bawling my eyes
out because i was so hungry and so
overwhelmed
and
what happened a lot of the time there
was he would bring in prostitutes
a lot of the time he would go and find
prostitutes and bring them there and
i remember just like covering my ears
all the time just covering my ears and
just
not wanting to hear this not wanting to
hear what was happening
but
all the different types of abuse
that he put towards me which was mostly
physical
there was sexual here and there but it's
it was mostly physical
and um
i ended up being in his custody until i
was like seven years old
so
um
you went to school yeah yeah um not
regularly i
i had to keep switching schools because
um
i was between like cps and foster houses
and polinsky
a lot of the time so i would switch
schools but i only missed i think i
missed
i got held back for two grades um i
think it was like second and
third i think but i got held back so
um and ended up catching up when i was a
little older by moving upgrades because
i was doing so well in school
and how old are you now i turned 21 in a
week
so you're still young yeah
but you you figured out at some point
that you have borderline personality
disorder yeah um
i was 17 i think and
i started noticing
that i've always had this issue with
relationships whether it be dating
friends whatever um that i can't keep
i can't keep a solid relationship
it would always turn into
whether it was fighting or distance or
anything like that i couldn't
maintain loving someone
really close from a distance it's okay
but very closely
it wouldn't happen so
i finally went to a psychiatrist and
started talking to them and they
diagnosed me with bpd adhd and
depression
um
which i mean is really common with
people in that have bpd they don't
usually just have one diagnosis and
there's a bunch of factors into it
but i think
i think the older you get the more you
kind of discover from the issues that
you have and that's personally what's
happened with me
so what kind of things have you been
through
um
because of this
i think
i gravitate towards people that are not
good for me i think that's kind of the
overall thing i think that i
i try and find people and fix them
because i can't fix myself
and i i have
no example of like what a good stable
relationship is
so it takes
it takes a lot of time
to
it takes a lot of time to
understand someone for me
and i don't
i think i'm attracted to
people who can represent my past whether
it be abuse or just anger issues
violence and it's because it's
comfortable for me
it's not healthy but it's more
comfortable than
finding someone and just understanding
immediately oh they're going to be good
to you they're going to love you because
they can and i and they want to and i've
never understood that that's probably
one of the harder things for me is i
just don't understand that people can
love you and there doesn't have to be
repercussions to it
um
you've had you've been in love before
yeah
that's
something about me is i love
i love people deeply
but
because of my bpd it causes me to split
a lot of the time which means
i can love them
a hundred percent feel on top of the
world
and then
i noticed
like as soon as they do one thing or
something said
it immediately turns to i hate this
person
i don't want to be around this person
and i don't
like that i don't like that i want to be
able to love somebody unconditionally
and love them
even if they make mistakes
but because of how intensely i feel
emotion
i don't
i'm not able to provide that at this
time maybe it will get better but it's
it's hard
you know i think it'd be hard to find a
partner who understands
that behavior
yeah nobody
nobody understands but i don't blame
anyone i don't i don't blame
my father i don't blame anybody who's
hurt me because people can only love to
the extent that they've been taught
and
you can't expect somebody to love
someone with all these issues when maybe
they had completely different issues
growing up or none at all
they are never going to get why
why little things make you mad
or why
you can wait i could wake up one morning
and just be
angry just angry for no reason
um and
sometimes i feel really bad because i'll
i'll snap
i'll snap a lot of the time like the
littlest things and i'll just ruin the
rest of my day
but it's something i'm learning to
kind of get a grasp on
are there any medications i think there
are
um there's nothing that treats bpd
directly it's like treating the symptoms
like a lot of people with depression
take lexapro
i tried that and it made me feel like a
zombie
so they put me on something with a
higher dosage something to increase
serotonin because that's a really common
thing in people with bpd is that they
don't have the right levels of serotonin
in their brain
um but there's nothing that treats it
directly
unfortunately
have there ever been times where things
have improved for you
um or is it just it's always with you
it's it's like having an angel and a
devil on your shoulder
the angel you really really want to be
that person and you want to you really
want to be that person and like
be good
but it's constantly in the back of my
mind
it's constantly there where it's like
you should get mad you should feel sad
like all the time
but
i'd say
the best times
the best times for me is when i'm alone
because there's nothing
that can
make me feel like something's wrong if
i'm by myself besides my own head and
that's something i live in every day
even if i can't control it or balance it
i can
try and
improve it with time
so what's been the worst thing you've
gone through because of this
um
i would say
losing my relationship with my adopted
mom like losing it for a period of time
because i felt when i was like 15 um i
ran away from home
for like two months and i blocked her
number
and i just out of nowhere i just packed
my things
and i left
because i i had my well 15 16 i had my
license i had a car
and
i packed my stuff and i just left i
didn't tell her anything blocked her on
everything didn't tell her nothing did
she deserve that
no
it's not her fault it was mine
um she's now i mean she's like my best
friend
but at the time and for a few years
after it was almost like
living in a house with a stranger
because we didn't talk
because i eventually did go back but
i did that because i felt unwanted it
wasn't anything she did it was i was so
in my head
that i didn't feel
loved but i was loved and i think that's
one of the hardest parts of having
this disorder is you get so in your head
that you can't even
see reality sometimes
there can be a room full of people and
if one person
says something or does something
it can make you think everyone in the
room hates you and
it's
it's hard
it's hard um
my
cousin my mom's sister's daughter like
blood cousin had bpd as well
um
and she
got the other aspect of it where she
fell into drugs very heavily and she
passed away when she was 16 from a
heroin overdose
and
the last thing that she she wrote a big
letter to everyone and the last thing
she said in it that resonates with me
every single day
is
i wish you could see
how i am in my head so you would
understand why i didn't want to be here
and i think
now getting older i'm starting to see
exactly that
it's you're so in your head you can't
even live your life
this was your
cousin who is a blood relative she's a
blood relative
so it could have been something you
inherited
probably
i'd say so
my mom
was
the same
kind of pattern where she would jump
from things she'd jump from partners
she'd jump from jobs
and it's it's so common
when you have certain issues to
certain issues dealing with bpd to want
to just be super
um
indecisive
so like she could have the best job in
the world uh she
she actually was
working as a um she was one of the
head techs
at a dealership working on cars
and she was making really good money
that was right before she got pregnant
with me she was making really really
good money and
i remember when i was told the story one
day she just never went back and chose
to
lose her house
lose her car lose everything
just because
and
there was no reasoning no rhyme behind
it and
i think that's a big part of why i have
it because
i think she
had it and no one took enough time to
care
to ask why she had the issue issues she
did you know
um
mental health's more discussed now in
the world we live in it's more prevalent
it's more cared for but it's still not
understood
and if you are
whatever you have
whatever issues you have or trauma
people don't
they'll never understand if they didn't
live it they can have empathy but they
don't understand
and they never will bpd has got to be
very difficult for your family and
friends and
relationships
yeah um my
my mom actually doesn't even know i'm
diagnosed
um
she
i choose not to tell her
um
not because i don't want her to know
but i just
don't want her to have the stress of
being like oh something's wrong with my
child like
a lot of parents are like that
it would help you it would help explain
your behavior
yeah in her in her mind yeah i probably
would because i'm very
um
i'll just react on anything i want to do
like if i want if i want to go shopping
and buy 300 worth of clothes but i know
i have bills to pay i'll still do it
if i want to
impulsively just like go out and trade
in my car and buy a new one i've done
that twice already i'll have a car for
like
three months and then i'll just be like
ah and then just go and
get into a bigger car payment or put
myself more in debt or
very impulsive
very impulsive and i think that does
affect
it does affect people around me
it sucks what do you uh what are you
afraid of what do you worry about
i think
i think i'm most afraid of ending up
alone
like in every aspect just because
i'm a very hard person to deal with
i love people i really do i love people
like no other i
but
when i love you
it's easier for me to show you my bad
side and
not necessarily bad but my
my problems
like if i have a lot of feeling for you
it just
it comes out because i'm so scared of
losing you
i think that's my biggest fear is i just
don't want to be left so alone because
nobody can handle me
and the only way i can fix that is try
and work on myself i think
so your your behavior will push your
partner away
even though even though that's the last
thing that you want
yeah like i've had
i've had friends um
like one of my best friends from high
school
he
you know
i think we were so close
um
he we were very close and he was always
right there for me and
i think
my choices of jumping from relationships
and jumping from
um really good contact and talking
really closely to
completely shutting him out he was one
of my best friends and i think he just
got tired of it
do your friends understand that you're
like this and and work with you or
tolerate it or or just help you write it
out
the thing is i feel like i
feel like that's the hardest part is i
don't feel like anybody is really my
friend
so i choose to not talk about it
um
feeling like you're not wanted is so
common for me
that i don't
i don't choose to get really close with
people so my acquaintances and people
that i would consider friends don't even
like them watching this is going to be
the first they've heard probably about
any of it
so it's almost like your bpd
works against you and almost sabotages
your
relationships in your life
yeah
it's um even though you're you're trying
to be
yeah a better friend a better partner
better
it's almost like it
it's a whole different person like i'm
grace
and this person
in my head
that does all the negative and like
does sabotage things
um
i hate that person
and it causes me to hate myself it's
like having a devil on your shoulder
yeah
another like
i think the biggest struggle besides
relationships with me is
personal image like self-image and just
insecurity
like in the i developed a
pretty
severe eating disorder like two years
ago
and
after about six months i started losing
weight because of it and in a year and a
half i lost 92 pounds
92 yeah 92 pounds
um
i was
i was very very unhappy and very
it doesn't matter like it felt like
something i could control about myself
because my head i can't control so i
could control the physical aspect
but
it didn't help because even now
going down all that weight losing all
that weight
i'm here
and i'm not happy
i think the biggest problem is no matter
what
what i see in the mirror
i'm never going to be happy with and
that's
one of the harder things
i think
what emotions are you typically what are
the most common for you is it anger is
it depression anxiety
anxiety
i would say is the most common all day
long like all day long
and i get shaken up pretty easy by
things
but it's more about things that aren't
happening like i think so much that i'm
anxious about something that's going to
happen a week from now or
it might not even happen um
and
i get angry
really fast
anger
and it's not it's explosive anger
it's not like
silent treatment stuff like that i i
just blow up
and
it's i'm so in my head that the person
sitting next to me whoever it is
won't even know that there's anything
wrong until i blow up
and then they just think you're crazy
yeah
yeah
it's something i've gotten better at
though i've gotten better at like
communicating
and saying hey this is not comfortable
for me or this is gonna make me a little
upset and i don't expect people it's no
one's responsibility to make me feel
comfortable
but i just feel if someone does love you
they can be understanding
um but my issues are no one else's
responsibility
so did you feel helpless against this
against
this issue yeah like against my own head
i feel like i
can't control my thoughts and i can't
control
my actions
but on the other end of that in a
positive light i do feel like
i do feel like i could
it's pushed me to be more just go for it
go get her kind of thing
like um
i i've always worked really hard i've
been working since i was like 15. um
you've had jobs yeah yeah yeah i've been
working
able to hold jobs huh you've been able
to hold the jobs
yes
but
um
after a certain amount of time
i'll just get tired of it i'll just be
like not interested and i'll go into the
same field like i
i'm a mechanic i'm ase certified i've
built and sold cars and that's that's my
passion
and i'll stay in the industry
and um
currently like i'm in i'm a manager in
part sales because i'm trying to buy my
own shop
but it's like i'll jump from like
different
parts stores and like different
dealerships
and it's not
it's not holding stability for me i'm
really bad at keeping stability
because it gets so boring to me um
but it does push me to go for what i
want
are there positive
aspects to this to bpd
i think that would just be the main one
is like and i think it's different for
everybody but for me
that
that jumping from thing to thing
is
it's bad
in some aspects but it's good if you
want to get a bunch of different
experiences and a bunch of different
work fields and work
areas i think that's a good thing um
[Music]
i think a positive
is that i do love people really deeply
too i love like i said i i think love
comes a lot stronger when you're way
more terrified of losing the thing you
love
but it can be
smothering
if you could have chosen at birth to
either have bpd or not seems like you
were probably born with it
would you have chosen to not have it
i wouldn't wish it on anybody
because you can't you can be happy
but
it's so
up and down
i don't think i've ever had a week
in
at least in the past few years where
a week seems so long to go without
breaking down
just just
getting overwhelmed and breaking down
and
it
tears you apart
and you still gotta get up you still
gotta go to work you still have to
do normal people things but you don't
feel normal
and drugs are not part of your life
no i mean like
weed
is
it's everywhere i mean i'll smoke here
and there but
i don't i don't do anything like that
it's great nothing crazy i don't do
anything crazy i've tried stuff
but i think that might be another
positive of bpd is that i'll try it get
bored with it and not do it again
so it's kind of
that's that's a one positive i think
um
but you feel like this is something you
were born with it wasn't because of your
rough childhood losing your mom and
dad on drugs
i don't know
i'm not sure i mean
because my mom had the same
characteristics and patterns that i
start to see now
um possibly
i might have been born with it but also
i think to the severity i have it
it could have been a little bit
manipulated and increased by my past
um the stress that you were going
through as a young child
yeah and when you're young
and
like just for me personally um
if you've been
like i've been molested as a child i've
had
adults numerous adults that i trusted a
lot break my heart and break my trust
and in all different aspects just
up and disappear
and just
do things that adults
should know will ruin someone when they
get older
um but
i mean ultimately
i think it's something i was born with
and i need to learn to live with because
i know
i know that up to like 10 of people with
bpd i've done a lot of research on it
just to try and understand my own head
and like
up to 10 of people diagnosed with bpd
commit suicide
and
i understand that
i i do i've attempted
but i couldn't go through with it just
because i love
life
as much as i do i do love life i just
don't love myself
so i think it's something i really want
to learn to deal with and not give up
because a lot of people it's so hard
that they they feel like they have to
give up and it's a sad thing
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned from all of this
it's a lot easier to let things go than
to let them
eat you
because especially with me i'll have
something in my head and it will just
like
like turn and turn
until
i can't handle it
i think letting things go and forgiving
people for things that
weren't ultimately their
fault
is huge
um
yeah
all right grace thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah
and i wish you the best of luck thank
you
thank you very much thanks
you